- Do you think we'll
ever see another moment
like GameStop in retail investing?
- I think what GameStop showed
is that retail investors
are a really, really
important part of the markets
and a constituency that can't be ignored.
And a big part of that is due
to the impact of
Robinhood and the mission.
- [Hannah] Robinhood was founded
with the goal of democratizing finance.
It's easy-to-use app made trading free
and spurred a generation
of retail investors
to jump into stocks, including GameStop.
- GameStop's shares is
absolutely going nuts.
- [Reporter] The weapon of
choice for these new traders
are platforms like Robinhood.
- But since then, Robinhood has lost
roughly half of its active users.
Now, CEO Vlad Tenev is
focused on growing Robinhood
into something more
than just a trading app.
WSJ caught up with him at
the company's headquarters
to hear how he hopes to make Robinhood
the most trusted name in finance.
What was the moment you knew
that you created something
that changed how everyday people invest?
- End of 2019, when basically
every single discount
brokerage in quick succession
lowered their commissions to zero
and essentially replicated our model.
And at the time I remember
being a little bit nervous.
You know, you get all these questions.
What does this mean for the company?
Like, we really have to up our game
to continue to differentiate
with our customers.
- What would you say is the next frontier
for democratizing finance?
- We've done a great job
with trading and self-directed investing.
Now the next area we're
tackling is retirement.
And so we're the first to offer a 1% match
in an individual retirement account.
And it's a big part of our journey
from helping customers
get started investing
to managing all of their finances
and providing service across
all of their financial needs.
- A lot of the investors I talk to
do still associate Robinhood with GameStop
and the trading restrictions
during that period.
So what do you say to customers
who lost trust in
Robinhood during that time?
- I understand that perception,
but what I'd point to is
the amazing progress Robinhood has made
and continues to make.
- [Hannah] Robinhood has gone from an app
that blasted confetti
after a user's first trade
to a company offering retirement
accounts and 4.9% interest
on uninvested cash for
premium subscribers.
The disruptive brokerage
is looking more like a
traditional finance firm
and with its acquisition of
credit card startup X1 this year
Robinhood has a credit card in the works.
- We think credit's a huge opportunity.
There's so many customers
that are either underserved
or not adequately served with
their credit needs these days.
And I think Robinhood can
play a huge role there
in democratizing that space
and make it easier and
a much better experience
to offer those products.
- [Hannah] This pivot to new offerings
is part of the company's strategy
to attract and hold onto users
in this high rate environment.
Trading stocks isn't as
popular as it used to be.
Investors now have other
options for good returns.
- One of the really interesting things
about the investing business
is it does tend to be cyclical
with growth coming in waves.
In times where interest rates are low
like they were in in 2020 and in 2021,
you see a lot of interest
in investing in the market.
And in other times there's
just less interest.
And so what we look at there is
how can we improve our product and service
and continue to innovate for
our traders and investors
with things like 24-hour market,
which makes us the
first in the US to offer
round the clock trading
for single name stocks.
- [Hannah] While getting
into retirement accounts
looks more traditional,
24-hour market is anything but.
It's a big shift in how
users can trade stocks
like Amazon, Apple, and Tesla.
- With 24-hour trading it just
seemed ludicrous to me that,
you know it's 2023 and
investing in the most liquid,
deepest markets in the
world, the US capital markets
is still tied to US east
coast working hours.
Everything is electronic elsewhere
and services are available
when people need them
and yet investing is
kind of this exception.
And when we looked into it
we realized that there's no reason
that it had to be this way.
We could work with counterparties,
we could build the technology
to make that better.
And 24 Hour Market, which
launched a couple of months ago
is kind of the first
step in that direction.
So I think it's still very early to tell
what kind of impact
it'll have market wide.
And I do believe in not too long
you'll see it become an industry standard
just like commission
free trading has become.
- If that does become
the industry standard
are there any risks you see involved?
- One thing that you have to remember is
we already have experience with assets
that trade round the clock.
If you look at the cryptocurrency markets,
they trade 24/7 worldwide and you know,
we've been offering customers access
to crypto on the platform since 2018.
- Speaking of crypto, it's
obviously been a hot topic
in the regulatory space
over the last year.
As one of the first
brokerages to offer crypto,
are you committed to offering crypto
to US customers moving forward?
- Yeah, and I think
crypto is here to stay.
There's definitely been a
lack of regulatory clarity
and I think we're gonna
continue to work with lawmakers
and regulators to push forward there.
- Shares of Robinhood have
had a nice run up this year
but they're still down about 80%
from their record high from 2021.
Do you think there's anything
the market is under
appreciating about Robinhood?
- Over a long time period
companies are valued on earnings growth
and the stock price tends to track that.
It might not happen for various
reasons in the short term.
What we can continue to
do is serve our customers,
improve our products, grow market share
but there's always more to do.
- Do you still think
Robinhood is an underdog
in the financial services industry?
- I do.
Robinhood's been able to
accomplish quite a bit
over the past 10 years
since we got the idea for it
but it's still a very young
company and I do believe
you know, 10 years from now
looking back to where we are today,
we'll really appreciate that
we're still in the early
stages of Robinhood
and there's so much to do.
- [Hannah] Even as Tenev looks ahead,
a reminder of Robinhood's association
with the GameStop craze is
out in theaters this month.
- And that stock is GameStop.
- Have you seen the movie "Dumb Money"
about the GameStop saga
in which you are a character in the movie?
- I have not seen it.
Having a movie created
that has Robinhood featured
is I think a really important testament
to the impact we've had
but you have to remember
the movie's fiction
and nobody sort of talked to us about it.
So I think I'm expecting it
to be a fictionalized account
and hopefully some of it's true.
(gentle music)